the most brilliant writer isn't
necessarily the one that's going to get
traction you need all the other parts of
the business the other parts of the
whole
if we put together a list of how not to
break in to the entertainment industry
what would five things be
five
how not to get work how not to get work
by Carol kirschner five ways don't put
in the time to develop your craft
don't reach out to people to find out if
they know someone who could introduce
you not a decision maker but just
somebody that might be willing
to meet with you zoom coffee for 10 or
15 minutes
somebody who does not want to enlarge
their community of relationships
um
something else not to do is don't be a
jerk and we were just talking about this
don't ask somebody you don't know to
read your script or get your script to
Steven Spielberg or somebody else
[Music]
um
don't be generous
you need to be generous there's so many
generous people in this business the
perception is everybody's like this but
somebody helped them so if you approach
them correctly and you are humble and
you are respectful
they'll give you 15 minutes of their
time unless they're a jerk and there
certainly are jerks
um
don't be annoying
is that more than five that's more than
five that's okay I'm enjoying this okay
well and I like what you say and the
thing is is that I think these
relationships they take time and so
we're in such a fast world right that it
can't just be you meet someone at a
mixer yes get their card or their
contact info and now you have to this
ask yes what I say and this I firmly
believe in first of all I hate the word
networking it makes me feel icky to even
say it I like the word connecting
if you make a genuine connection with
somebody
then follow that up
um
don't ask somebody for something
when you don't know them think about if
you were working and somebody said to
you I know you got a full-time job but
will you do X for me and only take you
an hour and a half
um
I always say and this is in my book it's
in my blogs it's the correct Hollywood
ask
you ask somebody for something but you
give them a gracious way out
so you might say I know you're
incredibly busy but would you have the
time to do X if you have the time would
you do X is there somebody I know how
busy you are is there somebody in your
office that would be willing to
X look at my script give me some
thoughts on it
um when you ask somebody to read your
script don't ask them for detailed notes
just say I'd love your general opinion
of it because that makes it just an hour
read instead of a two hour Endeavor
because nobody in the entertainment
industry wants to say no to you because
they don't know unless they're a jerk
again there are jerks they don't want to
say no to you because someday they may
be working for you or looking for a job
from you so make it so that it's easy
for them to decline if they have to
what are the assumptions most new
writers get wrong about the business
that everybody's awful
that nobody wants to help them and
that's often because they don't know how
to do what we talked about the soft
Hollywood ask
that it's easy I think that's a big
assumption that newcomers have that it's
easy they read a story about one person
who made it like that and they think
that's going to be them
they assume they don't have to do a lot
of work that somebody will like them
enough that they'll go okay you keep
yeah I like you I'm going to hire you
and let you get better while I pay you
that would be a bad assumption
what are some common excuses you hear
from new writers whether they're bad at
pitching themselves or you know things
about the entertainment industry that
are that you see you know what you're
you're putting up roadblocks you're
you're making excuses
if you're bitter
and you don't like people and you think
everybody's out to get me
that will not help you
if you think
I'm just in it for what I can get and
not how I can help somebody
that's a problem because that generosity
of spirit goes so far it really does
I always say be kind there's no downside
to being kind and you never know who
you're going to be kind to who later on
will go wow that person was kind I want
to help them
sure I'm all for kindness but you can
also be stepped on and taken advantage
of true don't be a doormat
don't be a doormat it is having
confidence without being a jerk
it is having a belief in yourself
without being annoying
and when you have that
you can think about how you can help
somebody else and not get stepped on and
you have to have self-esteem this
business it it may feel like it's kind
of wearing you down but you have to have
self-esteem in order to put yourself out
there in order to sell something in
order to sell yourself
I think a small bit of delusion helps
though and so because if you're too
aware of the odds you'll never do
anything
here's what I see
people break in every day
why not you
and that's what you should tell yourself
somebody's breaking in today why not me
well maybe because you haven't done the
work it may be because something else
but if you have and you're truly ready
why not you keep that in mind
and you mentioned bitterness and
although that word is is definitely a
negative
I think there's a healthy sense of
putting up some boundary sure because if
you're too open and you're too
fresh off the bus and you think this is
all wonderful and and take things at
face value you're going to learn very
quickly that's not how it is you
you should
be mindful you should read the room read
the business
and not lead with your heart on your
sleeve that doesn't help you it need you
need to make sure that it's sort of a
safe place to do that and
I think that if you're a puppy dog oh my
oh my oh my
um
that will not serve you but if you're
genuinely enthusiastic with confidence
that will serve you people love passion
and enthusiasm but if you're oh my look
at me look at me look at me look at me
that's going to be a problem
a vetted writer versus an extremely
talented writer which one is going to
succeed the vetted writer
because you have to have a level of
talent in order for people to want to
help you to recognize your talent
somebody with raw talent
let me tell you Talent is important but
it's not the most important thing it's
whether people want to help you whether
you are generous I talked about generous
it's whether you're meeting enough
people it's about do you have the right
work ethic it's do people want to be
around you
the most brilliant writer
isn't necessarily the one that's going
to get traction you need all the other
parts of the business the other parts of
the whole in order to succeed raw talent
is a fabulous place to start but you
have to know what the business is and
know what else is needed